so what is wrong with these people huh
has the alcohol Czar gone too far
President Biden's alcohols are Dr George
koob
tube that's a funny name sounds like a
weird Australian bird over here we have
the cube
that was a terrible Australian accent
and I apologize
anyway this dude he says the USDA could
revise its alcohol recommendations to
match Canada's
where is that anyway people are there
are advised to consume only two drinks
per week
oh I know why clay why are we copying
Canada we just talked about it Canada's
getting everything wrong and we're going
oh we're going to do two drinks a week
because Canada does it
can we just make this the campaign for
republicans in the midwest have you ever
been to a tailgate with the Green Bay
Packer fans
can you imagine going to him being like
hey guys you get two beers this week
yeah make sure that you just drink the
bare minimum that doesn't get you
remotely drunk like why would you only
want to drink two beers yeah except in
the first place if you're gonna go be
here go strong I think this loses
Minnesota I think it loses Wisconsin I
think it loses Michigan the Midwest
loves to drink this is absurd and by the
way the guy's name being Kube sounds
like it's a made up uh headline in the
first place yeah you know two it's funny
I mean David it's like you get two beers
a week without drinking like you can get
two you can get two alcoholic drinks
just by accident being at a bar I mean
you're not even drinking what is the
point
well you know I'll actually be uh one
year sober on August 28th 2024. I'm
gonna give myself the weekend
I'm gonna give myself the weekend
then we're gonna start
[Applause]
starting Monday
so great
you should go to an AAA meeting like
that
[Applause]
I mean hey look nothing but best wishes
to my friends in recovery but you know
do you know what the um you know what
the guidelines are right now
no yes who cares
what do these people get paid for right
it's so true no one cares I I will have
a meeting with my doctor it'll ask me
how much I drink and I go what am I
supposed to drink and it's like well and
then I don't even say
it's always three to four you should
have more than three drinks a night
right or two drinks a night and it's
like that I'm sorry that's not even it
that's not even gonna resonate in my
life I have to have
Greg we're all here today
[Laughter]
this isn't a show this isn't it
family in the audience
guy from Intervention
[Applause]
Dagan how healthy do you think this
jackass is Mr Kube he's like I drink a
couple of glasses of one a week how many
Donuts do you eat every day
this is meant to make people nervous
which nervous people drink so I don't
understand that and I thought about this
okay what's going to kill me first Hooch
or the psycho who's riding the stolen
bike around my block all day long every
day with the giant golf umbrella that
he's using as a jousting Lance
you know what it's not the bourbon
that's going to kill me
[Laughter]
um
[Applause]
why why does Seth Meyers keep doing that
[Laughter]
I don't know
it must be the strike right yeah it must
be this strike you know cat uh many
people don't know this but you can you
don't drink barely I've I drink very
rarely yes uh because alcohol is a
poison but also as a poison as far as
poisons go it is fun
um so I think people are always weighing
that I don't think anybody's thinking
really like the more I drink the better
it is for me but it's just everybody
just makes their own decision and like
you said people don't really listen to
this stuff anyways but I've actually
been averaging like two or fewer drinks
a week all summer because I'm so busy oh
look at you oh I'm so I'm too busy to
have fun that's what Lonely People Say
lonely people oh I wish I I haven't seen
any movies I'm too busy no no one wants
to go to a movie with you
oh I'm about averaging two drinks a week
because I'm so busy this seems like a
very healthy reaction that you're having
let's see
not at all not at all an indication I am
Greg you know we just are worried just
you know when I'm so out of here I'm so
out of here I I didn't know who who did
this
I thought you were about to unzip your
sweater
with my eyes
right only alcoholics wear zipable
sweaters
[Applause]
this is like a like a Ray Liotta
Goodfellas era you know you should be
diving out of a convertible in front of
a house and just beat
some guy with a gun
dude you look at her anyway all right up
next are we going to resent the
questions you sent hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else